dear fellow scholars this is two minute
papers with károly on alpha here earlier
we have talked about a few amazing
algorithms to teach digital creatures to
walk and this time we are interested in
controlling the joints of a digital
character to not only work properly but
take into consideration its surroundings
this new version can navigate in 3d with
static and dynamic moving obstacles or
even dribble a ball toward a target
loving the execution and the production
value of this paper this is accomplished
by an efficient system that consists of
two controllers that are represented by
learning algorithms one the low level
controller is about maintaining balance
and proper limb control by manipulating
the joint positions and velocities
appropriately this controller operates
on a fine time scale 30 times per second
and is trained via a four layer neural
network to the high level controller can
accomplish bigger overarching goals such
as following a path or avoiding static
and dynamic obstacles we don't need to
run this so often therefore to save
resources this controller operates on a
course time scale only twice each second
and is trained via a deep convolutional
neural network it also has support for a
small degree of transfer learning
transfer learning means that after
successfully learning to solve a problem
we don't have to start from scratch for
the next one
but we can reuse some of that valuable
knowledge and get a head start this is a
heavily researched area and is likely
going to be one of the major next
frontiers in machine learning research
now make no mistake it is not like
transfer learning is suddenly to be
considered a soft problem but in this
particular case it is finally a
possibility really cool I hope this
brief expose fired you up to this paper
is a bomb make sure to have a look as
always the link is available in the
video description and by the way with
your support on patreon we will soon be
able to spend part of our budget on
empowering research projects how amazing
is that the new two-minute paper shirts
are also flying off the shelves happy to
hear you're enjoying them so much if you
are interested
get up two minute papers calm if you are
located in the US the EU and worldwide
stores link is available in the video
description thanks for watching and for
your generous support and I'll see you
next time
[Music]
[Music]